your property you know what my trade
first thing you learn when you're there
okay good evening everybody
okay ready so welcome to politics and
prose tonight my name is Jonathan
woollen I'm the event coordinator here
thanks for coming out on this this
holiday just a few notes before we get
start before we get started here after
the event if you could fold up your
chairs and lean them against something
solid that would just help us with
cleaning everything up after there will
be a question-and-answer session as well
and we do have a microphone right off to
my left by this pillar over here so when
you do have a question if you could
speak into the mic just so we can all
hear you we also record our events and
c-span's here as well
so we want everyone to everybody to be
able to hear what you have to ask that
would be wonderful
and please do turn off your cellphone's
now as well so the night of the 2016
election as the night was winding down
and a Donald Trump presidency became
certain you might have been watching CNN
and and you might have heard Van Jones
go off script and say you have people
putting children to bed tonight and
they're afraid of breakfast they're
afraid of how do I explain this to my
children that was a terrible Van Jones
impression but it's it's a quote that
resonated and this book how do I explain
this to my kids as part of the proof of
that inside are short essays from
novelist journalists and more all of
whom for the sake of this book and and
because of the election results are
reckoning with their responsibilities as
family members first and foremost and
we're very happy to have three
contributors here tonight to discuss
their pieces and where they fit into the
conversation as a whole going from this
side we have been Wofford contributing
editor for Politico who has also been a
frequent contributor to Rolling Stone
right here we have Mehdi Hasan columnist
at the intercept and host of al Jazeera
English's up front we have dr. avi
Sigler who's commentary and the back
half of the book tackles the title
question of the book head-on she's a
practicing child psychologist former
director of the Institute for child
adolescent and Family Studies and author
of the landmark book what should I tell
the kids and joining them to moderate
the discussion right in front of me is
Jonathan Wiseman deputy Washington
editor at
New York Times and author of the
upcoming book semitism being Jewish in
the age of Trump so please help me give
a warm welcome to all of these writers
[Applause]
so as moderator I'm glad that Jonathan
put it in that shameless plug for my
book which comes out in March but a
friend of mine from from work told me
about this and been Wofford's work on
this and asked me if I thought that it
would be something I'd be very
interested in obviously I am very
interested since I've spent the last the
last nine months working on my own book
on being Jewish in the age of Trump
which is you know I actually have a
fairly delicate subject because there
are obviously some very prominent Jewish
members of the of the administration and
White House as there are very prominent
members of the anti kind of anti Trump
resistance especially on the Republican
side but I thought that this was a
fascinating book I've put this together
assembled the the introduction got all
these all these wonderful essays
together and also then trying to answer
for herself at the back on what do we
tell the children and if you look at the
essays you see a lot of them were
written very early what would I tell my
children the day after the Trump
election and I want to start this off
asking asking especially many because he
wrote about election night and what it
meant for his children his little girls
who were here what he would say to them
well it's now you know a nine months
later ten months later it's ten months
later and I how do you think it's played
out since that since those early days
Thank You Jonathan and thank you
politics and prose for hosting us and
yeah ten months nine months it feels
like 9 or 10 years yes to be honest I
mean it's like this this presidency is
more like you know dog years or whatever
the equivalent is for Trump years and
how is it played out unfortunately those
of us who were worried in the vehm
that those of us who were worried in
genuinely inauguration are still worried
and I think those of us who were worried
were right to be worried in many ways
we've been vindicated in our worries
about the nature of this presidency the
impact on citizens and children the
impact on minorities and I wrote that
piece for The Guardian shortly after the
election which was included in the book
from the perspective of a Muslim parent
but as we see across the course of the
book this goes way beyond Islam or
Muslims or a particular minority group
in terms of you know how did you talk to
your children about a president a person
forget president like Donald J Trump and
we just saw recently Joe Biden former
vice president not a man known for being
always eloquent makes his own gaffes
mistakes tweeting out you know our
children are watching enough of this mr.
president when he heard that the
comments about the football players
kneeling when the present you know how
do you even cover such remarks in a
family house or there were jokes during
the election which is you know my kids
can no longer watch the news because of
the language that's being used whether
it's in relation to women or relation to
minorities so nine ten months in no I
just think the same worries and from a
Muslim perspective deeply worried we've
seen the departure of Gawker and the
departure of Bannon but Trump himself is
more than enough to keep us all occupied
and awake at night I don't know if this
is too personal a question but how did
how have you talked to your to your
children there obviously it's a good
question and I'll be honest with you I
mean having read Alvis chat which I
highly recommend about the tips for
talking to kids you know I don't follow
many of those tips I did the classic
just brush it under the carpet look away
and I write I write in the book about
how my daughter came down in the morning
my daughter's very excited about the
idea of a Hillary Clinton presidency and
you know she said oh and she fell asleep
on the couch like most kids did I think
that night of that age and she came out
sure did she win and I said no and she
said oh so we won't have a female
president I thought to myself we have
way more bigger issues to worry about
than that and I think even now yes we
try and talk more about it said she read
the chapter finally hadn't shown of that
piece unwritten because she was coming
in at her and I mentioned the book
should she read the chapter we've talked
about it and I say what I say in the
book which is you know it's very hard to
discuss this with a child and I'm just
very very cautious
and I say stuff like don't talk about
politics in school don't talk about
religion in school if people talk about
Donald Trump on the bus and apparently
they all talk about Donald Trump on the
school bus you don't join in and if they
do say come and tell me what they say
it's it's it's unfortunately an approach
based on fear and caution and keeping
your head down which is not what I do
for a living but I would like my
children to do that for now I love you
know what you think about that I mean
you're in your book you talk a lot in
your section of the book you talk a lot
about what your what your children how
your children should respond if they see
bullying if they see the reverberations
of kind of trumping and boorishness
around them
I think Magni is worried about I met
Thea is worried with this his children
about actually them being the target of
that bullying is there a different is
there a different approach that you
would take as let's just be frank as a
white kid sitting on that school bus and
then you would if you're if you if you
are Muslim if you are brown skinned if
you might might be keeping your head
down because you might be a target I
think that the role of all parents is to
be protective of their children that's
our major role to enable them to grow up
in healthy ways and to develop into
civilized human beings which is becoming
increasingly difficult to do I believe
that you can talk to children about
these things but you must keep in mind
what the developmental age is what it is
you're pitching and what your child can
understand for example I think that for
very young children let's say they
express a fear you know I'm I'm brown
mommy you know president Trump doesn't
like brown children is he going to send
me away I think that what you do with a
very young child is to reassure that
child realistically we're here to take
care of you we wouldn't let anything
and to you President Trump is only one
man with an older child what you do is
increase their knowledge of the
situation you teach them a little bit
about civics you teach them about I'm
sorry can you not hear me you you teach
them a little bit about the Electoral
College you you point out that a
majority of Americans voted for Hillary
Clinton that we wound up with Donald
Trump has a kind of civic fluke I think
that with adolescence you engage them in
the idea of being able to change their
world a child that is now 14 years old
will vote in the next election so I
think it's very important to include
children in what's going on now as a
parent you have to be careful if you
over expose your child let's say you let
her watch whatever is going on on TV and
remember that Donald Trump is a big man
with a loud voice who says the same
things over and over and over again in
baby language even a three-year-old can
understand what he's saying this is not
a good thing
only a three-year-old he could oh yes
but I feel if you if you over protect
your children
you also deprive them of an opportunity
to learn very important skills that
we're going to need in our increasingly
complex world so I'm a great believer in
telling your children as much of the
truth as they can manage and you can
handle then I want to talk to you about
your essay which was about millennial
Jewish kids or I guess we can call kids
millennial Jewish young adults who
really grappling with the even the
concept of anti-semitism for the first
time I I had this experience where my my
stepdaughter we were
vacation and we were having this
conversation and trump was kind of it
was he was just barreling through the
primaries but really everyone still
didn't believe that he was going to win
the Republican nomination much less the
presidency and I remember sitting in
this restaurant in Iceland and my
stepdaughter said wow she's she's very
woke and she's very concerned about
everybody else but Jews and she says
well this is ridiculous there is no such
thing as anti-semitism that is what we
there's racism there's sexism there's
everything but there's no Jersey the
same semitism and I remember and I'm not
particularly sensitive to these things
but I remember like that was like the
shock like no you can't think that way
you can't you can't let your guard down
and then you know over the course of the
next six months for now it's now over
more the course of urine a bit we saw
this sir upsurge and in anti-semitic
violence we've now seen what what we saw
in Charlottesville with Nazi flags and
and Klansmen what do you think where do
you think that kind of sleepiness on the
part of that jet of your generation came
from well it's a great question
obviously and it presumes a couple of
things you know correctly one of which
is that there is a dichotomy of mind and
sort of spirit politically that is a
little bit like what Mehdi described but
in miniature and it's I think precisely
because it's you know far less palpable
than the sort of driving defining
leitmotif of Trump Trump ISM the Trump
presidency has based 10 years before we
had Trump is Islamophobia and that
cannot be denied whereas you know Trump
doesn't really seem to say things it's
all rather oblique he's sort of he never
says anything negative about Jews but
rather you know he finds fellow-feeling
with those who do you know there are
things that are tweeted that shouldn't
be tweeted so I think you know perhaps
you know to your question about the
sleepiness it could be kind of the
premise here is that it's not one of the
screaming
defining things of you know Trump's
worldview and the trumpian sensibility
but I think the other thing that's
really interesting and one of the
reasons I'm so glad that we have
Jonathan here who's working on a book
about this topic and I'm sort of eager
to be enlightened from you know another
direction on this because you know you
write that you grew up in Atlanta and a
reformed synagogue and never sort of
dealt with these sorts of things and I
don't actually know how old you are but
you sold you seem young enough that a
generation of parents who are right in
the middle of this generational divide
that's very particular or maybe not but
I think certainly you know palpable in
young Jewish circles which is do we find
common cause you know in the spirit of
of being on the right side of these
social justice causes while we have the
crisis going on or do we look inward and
identify you know things are sort of
marginally anti-semitic and it's I think
especially in the center-left crowd
which is very active in you know
fighting Islamophobia very active and
black lives matter in these various
causes there really is a sense a
wrenching one of a trade-off between do
we you know spend the next five years
educating people about anti-semitism or
you know do we you know you know
practice good stewardship or a lie ship
or whatever sort of the vernacular isn't
person I would say the way you deal with
it for me is it's you know these are
different phases of the same bigotry
right and Muslims have been saying for a
while we are the Canaries in the coal
mine you know people turned a blind eye
to Islamophobia for so long and said oh
you know this is not a big deal or this
is all about terrorism and it's no
coincidence these are the same people
push in many cases not all cases been in
many cases pushing that language when we
saw those horrific images out of
Charlottesville in the Vice document
saying Jews will not replace us a lot of
those guys quote unquote the old Reich
came to prominence saying things about
Muslims it wasn't actually all right the
first time we saw them a couple of years
ago then the owner was talking about you
know Islam and Muslim rape culture
Breitbart headlines about quote-unquote
Muslim rape culture and then suddenly we
were actually there at for the old group
was the old the old victims haven't gone
away that the old hatreds haven't gone
away that and people that Trump's a
divider and I see as a divider but you
know what he's brought Muslims and Jews
together
that's official since since January I
mean it is I absolutely agree I actually
that it is and that is I mean that is
where I come down that this is that to
fight anti-semitism or anti Islam or and
or our our anti-immigrant sentiment is
ultimately futile that this is all of
the same stripe so if you still fight
one you're just you're just squeezing
the balloon and letting the arrow come
up somewhere else so I absolutely do not
believe that this is a time for any one
group to focus inwardly on on its plight
I think it's very important I mean maybe
I have an extreme point of view but
Trump is a national disaster he is in
every way his personality and his
politics are lethal now even if you
agree with some of his politics and
there are many people who do who are not
necessarily racist or Slama phobic or
anti-semitic his personality is to
dislike be suspicious of and be
aggressive toward anyone who does not
resemble him this includes women it
includes blacks it includes Browns it
includes as Islam it includes Jews it
includes I mean there's cricketer would
include Kurds it does not matter it
includes immigrants from all countries
he is a xenophobic bellicose disturbed
individual and therefore we don't have
to choose of this array of what he's
against he's against anything that does
not feel familiar to him and he projects
his own hatred on to that particular
person that particular group
and it is really quite horrifying
because the discourse in this country I
think one of the contributors is not
here today said we've gone from the
whisper a quiet whisper to the roar of
the crowd all of these things they've
always existed it's not like there
wasn't any anti-black feeling we went
through the civil rights era in this
country blacks were being lynched it's
not like these things are new but Trump
has raised them to a level that we have
never seen before and he's normalized it
so it's extremely important this is why
I think it's important for your kids to
to criticize what he says and to correct
it for them no immigrants don't cause
crime in this country in fact immigrants
have a lower crime rate than people who
were born in America you know it's
extremely important because he's calling
into question all of the aspects of
civilization interestingly you say and
you say this in the book very wisely
about the importance of teaching facts
which is something you know a response
to Trump is to double down on the
importance of reason and the importance
of debate in the importance of facts and
that is one of the things that I worry
so much about which is a partly to do a
trumpet partly the wider society we now
live in you know that debates about fake
news polarization information bubbles as
a parent you do wonder you know what are
your kids are going to be not just
learning what are they gonna be
absorbing in years to come what what's
gonna unite them you know when we were
younger we could all go in I could go
into I could go into work ten years ago
and know that the person next to me
probably watched the same TV show the
night before had seen the same news
bulletin we could discuss the same front
page of a newspaper now we live in an
age where already people are doing less
and less of that any other president who
is encouraging it who is dee-lish it
amaizing the media telling people not to
read this not to watch that this is fake
this or even today's tweet and
yesterday's tweet and also social media
our kids are also on social media and
way they weren't in the civil rights
movement you probably you probably could
have protected your kids much better in
the 1960s from what was going on in the
south
then you could today in terms of you
just go on Twitter and see the president
saying outrageous things my question
about fact I mean it seems to me that
for our children I see this my own
children
fact is one thing in zeitgeist and not
is another and the the the the upswing
in intolerance in high schools and
middle schools especially maybe not
Elementary's maybe we see them in the
military but I my kids are high school
and the rise of intolerance the rise of
racial incidents and things like that I
don't think they're driven by facts at
all is driven by a zeitgeist and I don't
know how do you how do you how do you
talk to your children about an
atmosphere do you want me to answer yeah
I think in every generation parents talk
to their children about the atmosphere
that atmosphere that we're talking about
is what we call culture we need to
establish whatever the values are that
we want to impart to our children in
psychology for instance there is
something we call identification with
the aggressor it's a very powerful
developmental experience little kids
looking at people who are powerful and
angry and looking at people who they're
bullying if they have to choose they
choose to be the one who's doing the
bullying the aggressor not the victim
mber the high school crowd during the
election who shouted build a wall at a
team of Hispanic high school students I
mean I was directly derived yes what was
going on on their TV screens on their
campus or make America great again
adios that's another thing you know that
that has been shouted I mean kids absorb
the culture it's infiltrated
particularly as you're pointing out in
this media age where their phones and
TVs and computers are constantly
surrounding them it makes the job of
being a parent harder but it means that
you have to work harder to make sure
your children have
I would say for civilizing
characteristics number one empathy
number two realistic self regard number
three morality and number four
self-control
well guess who doesn't have those four
exactly it is no mistake that I say he
is an uncivilized president these are
the things that all civilizations
attempt to work towards there's another
your story about the school children who
were chanting build the wall I mean
there's this sort of adjunct issue to
this whole debate which is you know
parents you know have negate a large
amount of the time of the you know of
their child's life to the classroom and
so I think there's another question here
about what do you do if you are a
teacher and that's a whole you know an
entirely separate kind of set of
questions but I've interviewed teachers
who are absolutely dumbfounded I mean
they through all sorts of political
reasons they don't want to broach these
issues in the classroom if there are
verbal or even sort of physical
obviously physical altercations are
dealt with promptly and immediately but
you know the grist for those
altercations remains and it's difficult
to adjudicate or teach away and and the
SPS PLC has done some outstanding work
on this they have a survey of I think
about 1,200 responses and you can find
this data set it's public and if you
read through it it's it's unbelievable
and also part of the issue here are not
surprisingly the teachers the teachers
will come in you know on the next day
their reports a teacher saying you know
we're gonna miss you when you're
deported you know something like that
and and there are more of these these
instances than you might think
in fact the ISP you think tank which is
a Muslim run think tank did a survey of
Muslim Americans a few months ago they
found that four in ten Muslim American
families identified bullying have said
that their children were bullied in some
shape or 14c election in the form of
anti-muslim bullying but the statistic
that jumped at me is one in four of
those cases involved a teacher not a
pupil doing the bullying this is a sense
of you sending your child to the
classroom but also you don't have to
worry about other kids we also have to
worry about the teachers themselves but
having said that let me just add one
point here because we have Muslims and
Jews on the panel a woman on the panel
will be down the
you can't represent everyone but you
know I would argue yeah I don't like
hierarchies there is a case for
hierarchy at the end of the day the kids
are having it most worked right now are
the kids of undocumented so let's be
very clear about that right now as we
sit here tonight there are people who
cannot go out at night who cannot go
down the street one couple took my kid
to the hospital had to go through a
Border Patrol checkpoint in Texas what
arrested while they were taking the kid
to hospital for a surgery one could go
into a prom high school trip high school
club to go to prom ice came and took him
so that that kind of fear I don't think
any communities experiencing on that
level thank God Muslim Americans
certainly aren't feeling on that level
not yet I mean I think after Las Vegas
when Las Vegas I think a lot of Muslims
went oh if this is a Muslim guy get
ready for the camps and and the new
bands but right now what is actually
happening to Latino kids especially the
kids are undocumented is outrageous and
shameful it is appalling and I do feel
that it's up to us again to educate our
children and those children the parents
of those children need to make a plan
for them they need to make sure that
they understand that their father can be
sent back to Mexico that aunt you know
Luise will take care of them that that
Nana will take care of them that's not
what it is in Spanish what is abuela
anyway you need to be able to help your
children understand when there is a
danger just the way people had to do in
Germany or they had to do in Russia when
they were going to be deported or they
were going to be captured or killed or
tormented I think it's very important if
you were in that situation to be able to
reassure your children what would happen
if daddy has to go back to Mexico it's
not that we want to alert our kids we
don't want to alarm them there's a
difference you can alert your children
without alarming them we alert kids all
the time we say don't talk to strangers
if somebody comes and says help me find
my puppy and come into the park with me
don't listen to them you know we're not
alarming them
saying this person is a sexual pervert
and he's going to pull down your pants
we don't say that we say don't listen to
somebody that would say that and in the
same way I think we need to say these
things to kids so that they are somewhat
prepared you can never be wholly
prepared you know there I was reading
about a 13 year old girl whose father
came to pick her up from school and was
right in front of her right in front of
her the ice officers came and pulled him
out well let me throw this out here
because obviously we were in politics
and prose and upper Northwest DC hardly
hardly read State Territory but there is
legitimate conservatism in the world and
in fact I think that you could find
fairly harshly anti-trump conservatives
who do believe that illegal immigrants
are illegal immigrants and they should
not be lumped in the same category as
American citizens who are being bullied
or you know people who are having their
rights violated another Constitution but
they're those they were born into those
rights whereas maybe somebody who who
came into this country illegally has a
different set of rights
now I'm not I'm not saying this one way
or the other but is there room to talk
to your children talk to your families
about about donald trump and trumpism
without necessarily being ideological I
mean what there is such thing as there
before Donald Trump there were
conservatives and liberals and they used
to kind of live together I completely
think that of course you can and you
know I have I have family members
extended family members who voted for
Trump and the argument we have and I try
and make this point a lot of us do is
this is not about Republican versus
Democrat you know people voted for
george w bush and people are upset about
that but you know i wrote a piece saying
I miss george w bush not because i like
george w bush but brick Donald Trump is
soui generous there has never been a
president before I could never
there has never been a leader before
like him in the United States and
therefore I think it's legitimate to say
to talk to your kids and talk to your
friends in your family in this kind of
extreme or unique way that the way
others talked about in terms of the
unique danger he poses the threat he
poses you know we if you know one of the
best cases against Donald Trump as a
human being forget as a president was
made by Mitt Romney during the campaign
if you go back to some touchy on the
political website I found it the other
day the transcript is still up where
Romney kind of piece by piece takes up a
pie his temperament his character his
business history Mitt Romney the former
presidential candidate is not about
ideology I mean you can have an argument
about Trump's ideology and talk about
you know tax cuts and whatever it is
immigration but fundamentally this it
for me it's not about that it's about
that the people say oh you get rid of
Trump you get pence yeah you get a sane
human being right so when you talk about
Donald Trump you have to talk about the
fact that he is unique and obviously you
know Romney slightly undermined himself
by then trying to be essentially of
state but then to one side but his
actual critique if you read that I would
start I would sign up for every word of
it and I do think there's a general
sense about that the the moral
degradation of the culture the the
boorishness the bullying the
thin-skinned is the vulgarity this is
not ideological this is not left or
right this is about just being to use
our space as civilized human being and
we lack that at the top of government I
think it's worth us all agreeing on how
many Republicans do not not enough but
some do John Kasich has talked about
quitting the Republican body bob Corker
just this week saying everyone worries
he's about to start a world war all of
my Senate colleagues agree with that
he's brave enough to say it because he's
retiring but others won't yes I I think
absolutely you have to remember what I
said in the beginning that we're talking
about a combination of destructive
policies and a lethal personality a
disturbed personality you know when I
spoke in New York somebody in the
audience said I could I come from South
Carolina what would you do if you were
talking to a bunch of parents from South
Carolina or people from South Carolina
and I said I would tell them is there
anyone in this audience who would want
to raise a child like Donald
is there is there anyone who would want
to raise a child like Donald Trump
impulsive ignorant you know a liar a
pathological liar you know regardless of
the policies we're dealing with
something that is extremely dangerous
because he's reckless
he has no idea no self-control
no empathy and he's the president of the
United States nine months feels like
nine years because look what's happened
in just nine months I want to ask you
that because you wrote you write about
this moment for parents as something of
an opportunity a moment to crystallize
the notion of morality and ethics what
it means to be a good citizen but is it
is it is it enough I mean is it enough
to overcome all that is around I mean my
kids also live on the phone and I always
wonder how much my advice to them sings
in when they are surrounded by by by
electronic nannies and and advice
columnist well I think all of us in
today's times struggle against the
massive influence of the media but with
young children remember you are still
the most important person in that
child's life it's only as the child
moves into adolescence that you lose
that special place so the time to do it
is now when your kids are younger and
moving into elementary school because
that's when you instill your values in
them then you have to hope that when
they hit adolescence the rebellion does
not take the form of a rebellion against
those basic values and you have to keep
talking we all have to keep talking this
isn't one conversation you know your
children live with you you have to keep
talking to the
you have to keep saying you have to let
them listen to Saturday Night Live and
see you know Alec Baldwin do Trump you
have to let them read things and share
things with them and express your
thoughts and feelings to them in ways
that they can understand but you're
right it's not one you're not gonna do
this easily but it's never easy to be a
parent you're always fighting against
the influence of the culture in one way
or another whether it's drugs or sex or
you know I mean it used to be Elvis
Presley I remember what I was growing up
Elvis Presley was the horror in society
you know look look how naive we don't
have any rockers to shock us any Marilyn
Manson go the the only one thing I would
say about I mean one day I say about
this whole concept of the idea of you
know what do we say to our children and
is very important as parents to say that
but what do we say to ourselves as well
I mean this is not just about children
as everyone in this room can testify I
mean the effect that Donald Trump and
the presidency has had on all of us
there's a phrase in the book I think
Molly kannathil uses about how because
he speaks in this direct language to
children what he says and what comes
across as a form of emotional terrorism
and as I read that I thought but I'm a
victim of that too in many ways I think
we all are
and there's another great book out
actually at the moment called the
dangerous case of Donald Trump by 27
psychiatrists and mental health
professionals I interviewed one of them
the other day Betty Tang who's a trauma
counselor in New York and in her chapter
of that book she talks about PTSD now
meaning kind of post Trump stress
disorder she said she sees it in her
clients you know she says this is real
stress it's she compares it to the
stress people felt after 9/11 and I
think you know you could argue about the
level is that exaggerated etc I think
there's no denying that we've all felt
overwhelmed by the daily diet of
controversy and shock and horror and
what next I live my life on Twitter as
my family will testify I get scared
going yeah this every morning it kind of
you know it's become a routine you shave
you shower and then you see what was he
said what he said at 7:00 a.m. this kind
of takes the question back to Jonathan's
you know point which was you know what
is the actual sir
almost pathological impact of being
marinated constantly and there's people
who friend of mine is working on the
story right now actually who believe you
know in 20 25 years we may understand
something about this in much the same
way we understand about McDonald's you
know 20 years ago or cigarettes 50 years
before that you know I guess you know
maybe to sort of volley this in the in a
direction I mean this isn't really about
Millennials right I mean this this
thought comes up with Twitter I mean
this is really about the next what does
it jens e or what's their name
I did have an eight I think they do have
a name I deserve Jersey yes they're
their post millennial so I don't know
what they I don't know whether raises
the children of Trump I come from the UK
where whole generation of a school that
shows children Oh which is do we know
anything about this generation I mean is
the jury's still out I mean do we know
anything about how they view the world
or their are we certain that they're all
you know spending exorbitant amounts of
time on the phone I mean what do we know
about this generation and what and what
long-term impact will as you know design
guy store culture will this have on them
because if you think about it you know
you grow up
if your child is growing up as mine in a
trump presidency and if Trump wins two
terms which is easily possible then
that's eight years of Trump not knowing
anything other than you know that's what
you define as president that's what you
define as a leader one of the things I
did a few months ago we were in Barnes
and Noble and I bought a book for my
daughter I remember picking it up and I
said you're gonna but you you should
read this book and as a biography of all
the prayers a kid's biographer of all
the presidents because there are other
presidents apart from Donald Trump you
need to know that you need to know that
not everyone is like this person there
are if there is FDR there is a Lincoln
you know it is my my kids are 15 and 18
so it's a little different but now
they're their stats their concept of a
president Barack Obama they think that
they think the presidents are quite calm
and reasonable so so it's it's an it's
it's kind of whiplash the contrast is
what making us feel all trauma
because there was a calm you know that
existed for eight years a child that was
eight years old or six years old at the
time that Obama is sorry at the time
that Obama became president lived most
of her life under the Obama presidency
where you know there was warmth between
Michelle and Barack the children there
was family there was culture there was
there were beautiful phrases not very
very very which is all you hear from
Trump this is very very very sad to be
fair Trump is quite warm towards his
children he gives them jobs what is all
around I actually have seen him touch
the Ivanka but I will talk about that
but I mean let's not get too far I've
gone on Obama hagiography but I will I
will say I read somewhere that living in
a stable democracy means not having to
worry what your government is doing
every moment and that's where our
instability comes from where we are
always constantly wondering what not
just others the rest of the world
nuclear confrontation on North Korea
started on Twitter right absolutely Minh
has any final things I wanted to throw
it over to open to the audience but I
actually had one questions you know
again sort of volleyed in general but
also sort of that you Jonathan maybe
this can initiate the
question-and-answer session but it seems
to me you know not to bring it back to
necessarily my essay but we have two
people up here who are also sort of
looking at the same particular whatever
cross-section of this on anti-semitism
and it seems to me that that's sort of
the one at the end of the cereal that's
somewhat dimmer than the other ones I
mean I wonder if you agree with that I
mean when we talk about you know the big
crises we're talking about we're talking
about even in Hillary Clinton's
candidacy for instance it was quite
normal to hear the candidates say
you know this is about women's rights
this is about people with disability
rights this is about people of color and
there wasn't anything at the end there
with a blank that said you know and
people fighting anti-semitism I mean is
that because of the problem in your view
hasn't escalated to that level of
urgency to sort of be interesting why
are you're writing a book about this so
I take it that maybe you think that
Blanc ought to be filled in in the
mentioning of sort of in the catch-all
list of things that we ought to be sort
of addressing well my lat might the
final chapter of my book starts with a
story about a guy named Kitty Kaplan
Kimmy Kaplan in the 1920s he told this
tells this story about how he but this
rabbi was telling me a story about Kitty
Kaplan huh Kevi Kaplan was this heroic
guy who went down to Miami and he had a
african-american driver and he was taken
to this he was gonna go to a country
club and he gets to this country club
and there's a sign on the on the thing
that says no Jews or dogs allow and he
looked he was just appalled and he
looked at his black driver his black
driver said well they didn't even
mentioned the blacks so he thought this
was a great an amazing story about you
know the the the rabbi who told me this
is about the the unity between the
african-american and the Jewish
experience in in twentieth-century
America but then I went in a red kitty
Kaplan his own story
kitty Kaplan actually was the first
white person if actually the alt-right
does not believe the Jews are white but
I'll just say Jews are white but it was
the first white person ahead the
n-double-a-cp
and as he as Kitty Kaplan told this
story he went down to Miami he had
actually had some business to take care
of in Central America they brought his
wife and his mother-in-law and left them
behind in Miami Beach he went down and
did his whatever he was doing down there
he came back up and his wife said hey oh
my gosh you got to see this place I
wanted you to go and see all these
amazing things that we saw in Miami so
he goes and he's gotta be does have an
african-american driver and he's an
african-american driver takes him around
he does see this it was a hotel he sees
a hotel it says no Jews or dogs allowed
and his response was wow I don't want to
give this guy my money he's avi is an
anti-semite and I'll just go somewhere
else he didn't really care that much and
his african-american driver turned to
him and said you think that's bad and he
started showing his his ID he had to
carry this ID with him and he said you
all african-americans in Miami Beach
have to carry this ID and if you get
caught and after 8 o'clock you were not
allowed in Miami Beach and if you're
caught you are thrown in the thrown in
jail and he went through this litany of
horrors that are that were that were
affecting blacks in Miami at that time
and Kivi Kaplan's looked at this and he
couldn't he was shocked and so he joined
the undef iecp and he devoted his life
to to civil rights and my point of the
in in the last chapter of the book is if
you think the Jews have it bad I mean
what the Jews have is enormous
organizational strength enormous
resources and the ability to actually
make change
if they actually see them if we see
ourselves as part of a whole and not
obsess over but isn't the uniqueness of
this moment that a community that has
done so well as a Jewish community that
has integrated so well there's thought
was beyond all this - anti-semitism is a
taboo in a way that other forms of
racism haven't mean isn't that what's so
unique the Trump is able to come along
and blow that idea up as well that on
the eve of the election he runs the last
campaign ad which is filled with those
anti-semitic images of Janet Yellen and
George Soros and nobody says anything
really it wasn't the big control cuz of
so many other controversies and as a
Muslim I look and think you know my
point or you know I used to I used to
say you could never say that about Jews
when I see a horrible Muslim head Lama
good because that would be my point of
comparison so there's a community who
are now being protected from that and
now I can't say that because now I see
people saying Jews replace us and the
president says very fine people and they
really should have been extra chapter in
this book and you know what do you tell
your kids
what does Ivanka say to her Jewish kids
well how does she tell him that their
grandfather threw them under the bus
Charlotte's ville no III absolutely I
mean when I was the reason I started
this
I started my book is because I and I I
had there were these these journal
Jewish journalists during the campaign
that when I went under a social media
assault and I was in the top 10 of those
who were attacked on social media on
Twitter and Facebook and wherever else I
think that the anti-defamation league
compiled all these statistics and it was
remarkable I came in at number five but
I so this was my experience and first of
all I didn't everyone says oh my gosh
how did you survive that I didn't really
kill I mean it wasn't that big a deal
but it was it was revelatory because the
the expressions of anti-semitism were in
some sense very new in that they were
very high-tech II they were hipster they
had they had what what the alt-right
kind of sees as as comic but they were
also so ancient
there was this the whole notion that I
was taught in Sunday school that Jews
were at once these rapacious evil
capitalists and they were left-wing
Marxists they were you know and they
were evil Zionists and they were evil
anti-science they were you know Jews
could be anything to every and anybody
and to see that come back up in this way
that I mean they use Nazi iconography it
was it was so oddly retro that was one
of the great startling things about it
well in an atmosphere in an atmosphere
in which you have uncivilized violent
vindictive behavior all forms of
bullying and racism begin to emerge
because there's no break there's no
natural normal voice of conscience trump
is not regulated by a voice
of conscience like most of us are we
know when we've gotten to a point where
we should shut up we know that there's a
little voice inside of our head that
says uh-uh-uh-uh
but he does not and you know this
because he's completely without guilt
he's shameless completely without guilt
now what could be more dangerous in the
world than somebody who is completely
without guilt
and you know I think I just feel that
all of this is an uprising that has been
manipulated by the vast lack of
civilization in this presidency and by
the way not exclusive to Trump
I mean his cabinet members you know the
members of the Republican Party how many
people have stood up and said this is
wrong you can't say that no I won't go
this far
what do we have two three people I think
we should be more concerned
I certainly hope we're not going to have
Trump for another four years but even if
we do I think we should be most
concerned about a generation that is
growing up with this kind of divisive
nough sand what we can do in the next
generation to help them be more empathic
tolerant civilized human beings okay I
would like to throw this open to to the
audience if anyone has any questions I
would we can we can keep talking forever
and we will keep talking forever if you
don't have more questions but if anyone
has any question or just comments just
shoot it our way
well I was just gonna start things off
so people could get ready you know that
this is slightly slightly off topic from
what we've been talking about but you
know a lot of other people's experience
has also been trying to talk to parents
like how do I explain this to my parents
and explain
I don't know from my perspective it was
working with the dad who was you know in
the middle of cancer and coming from the
complete other side of the aisle for me
politically and not like dreading that
conversation coming up because I don't
want any raise tension to happen so I
don't know that's just a general you
know it's not outside of children how do
you talk to other people that you know
and I will say I mean I la I really am
very conscious of making the distinction
between talking about Trump and Trump's
behavior and talking about ideology
conservatism liberalism I honestly I
actually disagree with avi I actually
think that there have been enormous
numbers of conservatives that have come
forward not enormous numbers of members
of Congress but that's not the
Republican Party the Republican Party
aren't just elected members of Congress
and I think that some of the most
eloquent sentiments against against the
gives the boorishness and the atmosphere
atmosphere that Trump has created have
come from conservatives and oh yes but
I'm talking about people who hold power
in Trump's I'm Trump's presidency I'm
talking about his cabinet I'm talking
about the Republican Party yes they've
been wonderful people you know who talk
all the time on TV you know Steve
Schmidt and I'd recommend Jeff Lakes
book because it is a stunner and you
really should read it so yep that's like
one of the two or three senators McCain
I mean anyway about far about pizza
parents okay yes well no I mean I you
know not that I have some special
insight into this but I finally at the
you know the conversation here tilts and
my axis you know because I'll I have
interviewed to the extent you know the
one can do you know something that's
substantive interviews with a couple
dozen young people you know varying an
age range from their teens and their 20s
who are trying to educate their parents
and I think it goes exactly to what
Jonathan said which is you know seeing
something that's the core and the sort
of fear it of which is ancient but its
expression is entirely new and hip but
retrofitted to these old ideas that's
not something that's easily explainable
you know mom I was harassed on Twitter
this is real will prove it
well there's this image of a frog his
name kept a you know I mean how do you
the conversation it's not quite as
straightforward as one might think
the the share of the I think the
interesting thing about the share of six
pointed star is that it's actually sort
of well I don't know I mean it struck me
as sort of one of the few moments that
it was actually really clear that you
know what I mean there ought it doesn't
mean they make it any less veritable but
just the fact that it was something that
was so easily explainable maybe to you
know a cross-section of various
generations but you know the again with
Trump there's never anything there's no
smoking gun which is I think the the it
was Leon Wiesel tear who said that the
the the whole point about anti-semitism
it's the only kind of hatred of minority
that elevates the minority you know
they're not sort of worms in the dirt or
they're coming to take our jobs it's a
secret cabal that sort of controlled
them and you remember when Trump went to
the Republican Jewish publication the
other thing there was any any any during
the election campaign yeah yes I'm a
classic anti-semitic trope but he did it
in a kind of I love you you guys are
great girl money but it wasn't without
shadow of a doubt or and this is my
finance used to have yarmulkes yeah I
don't want black men counting my money
just guys in your milk is which is when
one of the biographies of Trump
apparently
allegedly said during his casino earning
days so yeah he's trading and only the
stereotypes I think either put it well
earlier you know he doesn't like
difference he doesn't like things he's
not used to one thing I would just say
about the whole young ol we shouldn't
get too carried away with the young old
division what's depressing and I don't
know how many of you read the town AZ
Coates piece on white supremacy in Trump
witches have pushback from others on the
left and liberals but you know the
statistics on voting are very very clear
Trump won every single white demographic
old and young middle aged and
Millennials every level every white
demographic Trump won so this idea that
it's a revolt you know it's just a bunch
of old angry nationalists who are out
you know don't like the idea and young
people are gonna come forward and and
educate the old and anyway time will
time will we'll win us with it winners
this struggle not necessarily true
unfortunately if you look at just at the
results of the last election yeah I
think to answer I think to answer the
question that Jonathan raised a little
more directly we talked to people all
the time about differences we say you
know oh dad you know just because he's
Italian doesn't mean he's in the Mafia
or you know we we talk all the time to
older people our peers younger people
about differences and the way we talk to
our parents is really no different than
the way we talk to other people except
we want to preserve the relationship if
you have an absolutely intransigent
parent you should not discuss politics
with him or her that makes no sense if
you have a parent you can talk with then
you can begin to explore this and the
way that we hope we're all going to
explore it I think it's very very
important you know to understand
Trump is the worst example of this but
we're not talking about anything new
these things have been around for a long
time and we've had to deal with them for
a long time it's not so long ago that
black men were being lynched in the
south it's not so long ago that Jews
were being you know cremated in ovens
you know so I think the these things can
be dealt with and should be dealt with
and there's no reason to suspect that
because somebody's your parent Mira
Jacob who's si is in the book talks very
movingly about the fact she's an Indian
woman with a brown son married to a
Jewish American man and her in-laws
voted for Trump they live in Florida and
they voted for Trump and her little boy
is heartbroken why did they vote for him
mommy he hates us why did they vote for
him and she very generously says to him
your grandparents love you no matter
what they didn't vote for him because
he's hurting brown people they voted him
for him from other reasons and we still
love them because they're your
grandparents now I don't know would all
of us be that generous I don't know I
tend to feel you know I would be a
little bit angry or funny but maybe not
whether your grandchild but but maybe
not you know so I think it's I think
there are ways to do this okay let's
this whole talk has been you know how
could Trump maybe have a negative
influence on children and teenagers it
could increase bullying it can increase
racism it could lower the effects of you
know could lower public discourse or at
least discourse among children to
teenagers on the school bus might it be
possible that it could have the reverse
effect and the reason I ask is if you if
you look at who children and teenagers
not just now but forever who are the
posters on the bedroom wall it's not the
president it's you know it's LeBron
James who said last week that he
wouldn't go to the White House if his
team on the NBA championship it's Katy
Perry whose most recent music video is
an entirely Trump bashing music video
might it be possible that there's
actually a silver lining like children
and teenagers the Millennials and post
millennial generation actually make a
conscious effort to not act like Trump I
will certainly say that my children are
much more political now than they were
and and we go to Green Day concerts and
watch them granted bail but that's a but
I think that's true I think that's a
good point and this was actually a point
that I I was talking about earlier we
taught we we look at this as a moment a
crystallizing moment where we could talk
to our children about morality and what
it means to be a citizen of the United
States but they are surrounded by all of
this noise coming from the White House
and from and from his and from the white
from supporters of the president so I'm
not sure but I'd love to hear your
answer it's not just noise I think it's
the cost it's the cost of that clearly
there clearly there are upsides and
clearly Trump is galvanized if you are
on the Left I'm not assuming everyone is
here but you know left-wing politics is
strong than it's ever been right now you
could argue with Bernie Sanders pitching
Medicare for all people joining the ACLU
donate you know people reading more
newspapers New York Times subscriptions
out because there's lots of the
positives you can point out in the
resistance to Trump I don't deny that
and clearly you know like I came of age
politically very much so during the Iraq
war 9/11 I was in my early 20s and yet I
was in University Australia University
for me that was a formative moment
tonight they go marching against those
Wars George W Bush was a hate figure of
my generation when I was in my early 20s
and
clearly there was a lot of activism
around that time and I wouldn't be who I
was today without those experiences but
you know at what cost hundreds of
thousands of dead Iraqis would I want to
go back and undo that yes and see when
you say is there a silver lining I said
there definitely is a silver lining
but let's not forget about the cloud
because the cloud is so huge and so dark
that whatever silver lining is it's just
not worth it from my perspective
what we call that is unintended
consequences there are certain
unintended consequences that are result
of Trump's positions and certainly it is
that there have been there's been more
interest in politics there's more
interest in politics among young people
as well as among all of us I never
watched the news I now can't keep my
eyes off the news
I think these unintended consequences
have resulted in the women's march on
Washington the largest group ever to
march and to mobilize and you see it
every Asian was twenty times and you see
it in all of the opposition the
judiciary opposition to what has
happened you know he's done an enormous
amount of things under the surface but
the legislative things that he's wanted
to accomplish he has not been able to
accomplish because of resistance and
persistence and that has been an
unintended consequence would you agree
yeah I was just going to simply quick
say that I think the lesson of your
point Bob and also many is it depends on
where you sit if you're watching your
father being taken away in handcuffs by
I see it's a different type of silver
lining you know but they're learning
grit so it's okay no I think that as
some people say you know absurdly
suggested but you know my short take on
this you read my essay which will soon
be disciplined many times over by
Jonathan's book you know is that it
there has been this palpable consequence
you now have cats chasing dogs and young
left-wing Jews lecturing their
grandparents you know card-carrying
members of AIPAC they're not doing
enough to call it anti-semitism and even
in the my friends sort of Jewish writers
here in Washington are much more
conscious of questions you know and
there's some great writers who've you
know
you know far more capable analysis and
understanding this issues frankly than I
am because they this is their beat you
know you can read Emma Greene's writing
for instance on you know do Jews really
classify as white no question I don't
think any many young Jews were asking
ten years ago and by the way the answer
matters because who is the architect of
the Trump immigration plan that we're
talking about when were arresting
parents is none other than Steven Miller
and so are you know are you white enough
to sort of have majority status it's a
pejorative effect or you know or if you
take the other side that you're actually
sort of a non-white minority then you
find yourself actually in fellow-feeling
with storm front which anyway by the way
I'm Steven Miller very brief I don't
know how many of you saw the New York
Times profile of him out today I think
in today's book which has a great line
from his rabbi saying we tried to teach
him morality and ethics don't blame us
is basically the quote from the rabbi of
his local synagogue as a kid but anyway
time but we can have time for these two
more questions that we medically yeah I
think the demonization of Trump here is
reaching the near hysterical levels it
sort of reminds me of what Hitler did in
Germany where he demonized the Jews is
this cabal that's can control of
everything and destroying everything
destroying the culture etc and I think
that you know you're in some ways you're
becoming kind of the ultimate example
the ultimate pathology of the game the
Trump is playing inadvertently well I
think I always am very very cotton I'm
very conscious to separate certain
conservatism liberalism and trumpism and
I do understand that but I'd like I'd
like you guys to answer this because
there is a question of whether or not I
mean how far you go are and how much
strength you give you give Trump when a
bet it was you who talked about
anti-semitism as the one
as the one version of hate that elevates
the that elevates the hate the hated
group it does all of this actually
elevate Trump's power beyond where it
actually deserves to be I just you know
I think one of the hardest things to do
is you know a writer who once in a blue
moon comes to these things to say I
don't know the answer to that question I
mean I really I don't I it's actually
one of the things that I'm sort of
wondering too because there is some
historical antecedents you know the
morning after the election my father
said and I don't think a sense you know
I would identify and it's clear in the
magazine writing as sort of on the
center-left and and so as my father who
said you know we lived through Nixon I
actually sort of think that you know the
worst thing we could do is go fetal I
thought of what Cote said this probably
is not satisfactory because it's buying
into the politicus of the question
itself which is no I'm not happy that
Trump won but I also don't think that
we'd be having this discussion of the
same way if someone like John Kasich had
won and maybe that's a distinction to
begin with or even my parents perhaps I
mean I made this point earlier as well
which is I don't think this is about
Republican or Democrat I do think this
is about the figure of Trump and with
respect I completely understand where
you're coming from in terms of how it
sounds and you know if I were the
proverbial Martian were to land here
listen to the discussion they might
think wow this is crazy you know what is
this person who is this Trump figure but
you know for those of us who
unfortunately or fortunately been
covering this guy for two years day in
and day out who's taken over our
professional and personal lives it's
very hard not to sound the alarm is very
not hard not to sound hyperbolic because
what are we supposed to do turn a blind
eye I mean there was this meme on the
internet after the election which is
this is why Trump won which a lot of
conservatives use anytime a liberal or a
leftist said anything that sounded it
could sound hysterical or or a Nazi and
now it's interesting that you use the
reverse Nazi analogy I've never heard
that one before interesting that it's
Trump who's the Jews okay
weird but but I would say that you know
they always said this is why Trump won
and my response always was what are you
supposed to do not say something not to
call out the craziness that we're seeing
in front of our eyes not are we supposed
to
turn a blind eye to the fact that the
president seems to be equating neo-nazis
with peaceful protesters are we supposed
to turn a blind eye to the president
just making up stories about you know
generals who tortured Muslims to death
are we supposed to turn a blonde I don't
know what I'm supposed to do I could
just stay started for tactical reasons
but but I'm not a politician
I mean in psychology this thing called
confirmation bias and the law of
attraction and I think we all struggle
with that I know I do
to what degree are we selectively
gathering our facts to feed through a
pre conserved film or or thesis or
ideology or whatever it is and how do
you you know gauge between well this is
my bias or what's objective reality
what's the truth and what is your own
personal filter and bias okay I'm going
to take a slightly different point of
view I respect the question that you're
asking and certainly I understand as a
psychologist about bias but I feel
really unabashedly that Trump is a
destructive and dangerous man I think
he's been disturbed since he was a kid I
think he was sent away to military
school because he couldn't control his
anger I think that in his real estate
business in New York he was known to be
corrupt to be racist to leave people to
be exploitative and now as president I
feel character counts character will out
now if you say to me well you know
you're being a little hard on him
you know he did everything he does isn't
wrong sure but most of the things that
he's done as president I believe have
been extremely destructive to our
culture our country our democracy and
and his own colleagues think so too
let's not forget that this is not a
partisan issue listen to bob Corker
today listen to the people who keep
quitting from his administration listen
to the people who keep briefing the
newspapers I mean Dan Dresner the
academic has a very running thing on his
Twitter feed which is I'll stop treating
the president like a child when his
aides stop treating him like a child and
always linking to the latest story where
we've got to keep the remote control
away from him we've got to switch off
the TV ID I said at the start I don't
know if you were here then but you know
I do believe Trump is soui generous I
don't think it's an issue of selecting
facts because of that were the case we
wouldn't be in this moment where people
from across the world across allied
nations across political divides are all
sitting worrying and wondering what is
going on here I mean for example can I
ask you one question back when when the
president threatens nuclear war on
Twitter how does that make you feel
unfortunately we do need to move on to
the next question I mean I would love to
have this I would love to have this
continued maybe right after because we
really do need a mailbox a that um it it
takes two to tango last question okay
all right okay I'm sorry
moving a bit more local to domestic
issues um we've got I've got four kids
between two and eleven and I'm hoping
we're raising them with some of the
values that you discussed a bit earlier
Ava and my concern is you know we teach
the kid me to speak out sorry is that on
even if there's you know issues of any
sort of racism discrimination you know
you speak out and you be empathetic and
you stand up for what's right you know
there's a right and there's a wrong and
we've had discussions about what
happened in Virginia but we're in
Montgomery County we live in a bubble I
speak to my neighbors many of them and
they say well no you stay in the bubble
like that's the way of dealing with it
like you don't push the kids out of that
but my kids 11 you know we could drive
two hours north up into parts of
Pennsylvania go over into Virginia what
a and I'm looking forward to reading the
book now some of the resources or tools
that we can provide our kids to speak
about these issues honestly and with the
notion of social justice and what is
right and not you know in dispelling
what's happening you know you hear about
the fake news and all of these other
things are going on but you want to
raise children that really value social
justice you know that will stand up
against misogyny but having the tools to
do that I mean they're in a good school
system so they're gonna get that but are
they getting encounter kids that have
had that same exposure and those same
messages and values instilled in them
not all the time no I think you raise
and one of the biggest questions that
parents have which is how far am I
willing to have my children express my
values in society
how far am I willing to go when I see
those photos of those little
african-american girls in their white
dresses going into school and those men
and policemen spitting on them you know
you're talking about civil rights yes
during the civil rights era I'm sure she
knows what I'm talking about I think to
myself would I be able to do that with
my child and maybe my answer is no maybe
my answer is no but look at the enormous
courage that they had and maybe those
children feel they were sacrificed
I don't know but every parent has to
decide to what degree are you willing to
have your children carry this on for you
in one of the essays a Muslim parent a
father talks about the fact that he does
not want his children to wear the hijab
to school he does not want them to talk
about it in school he wants them to
become Americanized whereas the mother
rewards the children and bribes the
girls to wear the hijab and tells them
not to speak up if anyone torments them
or bullies them because it's important
to live in peace so you have to
religious points of view in the same
family in the same family your 11 year
old has to be able to think is this a
safe place to talk is this a safe person
to talk to should I keep my mouth shut
here you know one of the women who wrote
an essay who lives in Florida says she's
in a Trump leaning in town her girls
already
say to her don't worry mommy we don't
talk about the fact that we voted for
Hillary so kids themselves begin to pick
up what is acceptable within their
culture and what is not and if they're
not in a culture that supports your
values they may keep quiet and that's
okay too
because we can't dictate to our kids how
far they should go to to carry on these
values we want them to do the right
thing but we can't guarantee that that
that's going to be what happens I mean
one thing I would say for a P at one
point I would make I think it's quite
important is you know values are very
important facts are very important but
also I mean just being there for each
other and for kids and this is beyond
just Trump I think in that current
environment we live in whether it's
anti-semitism or Islamophobia or racism
or other thoughts of bigotry or misogyny
you know there is unfortunately a lot of
heat out there and I think standing
together and standing with your children
I was on a panel with Linda Sarsour
recently the new new new york civil
rights activist we got a very good line
she said look the greatest act of
hashtag resistance that you could do
right now is give your kid a hug every
morning before they go to school because
that could be the only love they receive
during the day the world is so full of
horrible division right now just that
constant reminder and I think that that
line is stuck with me
because I think you know the very
minimum that's the least that's the very
basic that we can all do it all right I
I will I will just say one thing that i
you know i think that i think the
intolerance does go both ways and my
kids talk about like the to trump
supporter kids in their school and how
they would always get Boyd so you know
intolerance can be practiced in every
direction and I hope that we all think
about that so yes
[Applause]